48 heures après la libération de deux
otages qu on rêve à igorre j enfermé
dans l'ambassade d'iran à paris depuis
cinq mois est sorti pour être entendu
par le juge d'instruction chargé de
l'enquêté sur les attentats terroristes
en france en 85 et 86 haïti le premier
vote libre depuis 30 ans à annuler les
partisans de l'ex dictateur duvalier
terrorisme de pays on compte déjà
plusieurs dizaines de victimes
marseille élections cantonales tels le
candidat de la majorité a été élu une
journée supplémentaire de détention pour
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann
marcel carton les otages français au
liban n'ont toujours pas été libérés
madame monsieur bonsoir les événements
se précipitent ce soir 48 heures à peine
après la libération de deux otages
français
vahid gorgi enfermé dans son ambassade
depuis l'ambassade d'iran depuis le 30
juin dernier est sorti en début de
soirée pour se rendre au palais de
justice de paris afin d'être entendu par
le juge d'instruction monsieur buluk
en tant que témoin dans l'enquêté sur
les sanglants attentats terroristes
survenus à paris en 85 et 86 audition à
laquelle il s'était toujours refusé
jusqu'à présent
vahid gordji est-il cette fameuse
contreparties demandées contre la
liberté des deux otages français
on peut le penser nous allons tenter d'y
répondre tout de suite mais avant cela
nous allons tout de suite rejoindre
hervé brusini en direct du palais de
justice pour les derniers événements de
la soirée hervé et bien oui daniel
monsieur gorgi est donc en ce moment
même dans le bureau du juge boulouque
nous allons tout de suite revoir les
images de son départ le juge boulot qui
attendait cela depuis plus de trois mois
à 17h57 donc la caravane partait sous
bonne escorte wahid gordji quitté
l'ambassade d'iran vous allez tout de
suite voir gordji il est là aux côtés de
monsieur reza haddadi le chargé
d'affaires iranien
quelques minutes plus tard le dispositif
de surveillance du palais de justice
était sensiblement renforcé
wahid gordji donc je voulais 10 est en
ce moment même dans le bureau du juge
qui instruit le dossier des attentats de
septembre 86 un magistrat qui a d'ores
et déjà inculpé on le sait une dizaine
de personnes dans cette affaire
toutes ces personnes appartiennent au
réseau du hezbollah
le parti de dieu pro iranien certaines
ont cité le nom de wahid gordji le très
officiel numéro de l'ambassade d'iran a
donc était bel et bien mis en cause dans
le bureau du juge maison le sait pour ce
magistrat
malgré le temps d'en quête il s'est
écoulé depuis que gordji était retranché
dans son ambassade
et bien pour le juge boulouque dans son
dossier il n'y aurait pas de quoi
inculpé wahid gordji en fait vous savez
le point sur lequel le magistrat était
particulièrement ferme c'était de
pouvoir interroger gordy ici au palais
justice et non denses dans ceux d'avant
dans l'ambassade d'iran pardon car ça le
juge le faisait souvent remarqué si les
charges avaient été suffisante
comment aurait-il pu placer gordji en
garde à vue dans sa propre ambassade
alors nous attend donc maintenant
l'issue de cette comparution avec une
passion ou pas inculpation d'après
certaines informations actuellement au
bourget un avion serait d'ores et déjà
prêt pour ramener gorgi à téhéran merci
revêt donc pour ces toutes dernières
informations ça c'était les événements
l'effet de la soirée maintenant le
premier commentaire pierre serra alors
vas-y gordji est il oui ou non cette
fameuse contrepartie demandée contre la
libération des deux otages français
écoutez d'abord je crois qu'il faut
rappeler une chose c'est que le cas de
gorges y va sans doute vous passez en
profits et pertes si on peut dire par là
par les justices française et je
constate que en orient il ya un proverbe
qui dit qu'entre va bien peut pas dire
tant mieux
il faut dire tant pis on en sort
toujours quelque chose eh bien je
constate donc les événements se
précipitent vous le dire est que gorgi
sa personnalité elle toute seule ne peut
pas être la seule contrepartie des deux
otages d'hier je crois qu'il ya au
contraire un mécanisme qui s'est mis en
place
et d'abord il ya un reversement de
vapeur sur peut dire jusqu'à présent
c'était d'abord à la france au
gouvernement français de faire en
quelque sorte preuve de bonne volonté et
après après avoir fait un geste dont on
pouvait espérer l'arrivée d'un deux
otages qui s'est produit à peu près
régulièrement depuis un an
et puis aujourd'hui eh bien non roger
auque et jean louis normandin sont
revenus hier et gorgi s'en va
aujourd'hui alors la vapeur renverser ce
que ça veut dire que en à l'initiative
je crois qu'on peut avoir maintenant
vers le gouvernement a dû en quelque
sorte reprendre un peu d'initiatives
pourquoi parce que l'iran a besoin d'une
part de redorer son blason
d'autre part du reste on image et
surtout a besoin
argent est probablement le monsieur
chirac lui disait hier qu'un à quoi tend
la diplomatie française le gouvernement
c'est à normaliser ses relations avec
l'iran les conditions d'indemnisation
c'est d'abord aussi le paiement de la
dette que la france a contractée à
l'égard de l'iran alors peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui je pense un deuxième
tiers de cette dette 300 350 millions de
dollars ont dû être payées pour arriver
à leur apporter les hautes alpes ce
n'est pas une rançon
ces paiement d'une dette et puis gorgi
sort on va voir la suite alors vous avez
dit début d'un processus
c'est ce que ça veut dire que d'autres
otages pourraient être libérés vous
savez ça on peut seulement l'espérer il
faut pas mettre la charrue avant les
boeufs ou savez que dans ce genre de
négociations un grain ça peut tout faire
capoter
et puis il a des événements extérieurs
qui peuvent se produire
effectivement on le dit partout on peux
pas vous dire quand ça va aboutir
nous on est parti sur un bon pied bien
alors voilà pour le point que nous
pouvions faire à 8h05 maintenant bien
sûr nous rejoindrons tout à l'heure et
virginie au palais de justice il ya du
nouveau pierre serra reste avec nous les
dernières a forcé donc auditions
devaient gordji par le juge
d'instruction et puis cette rumeur selon
laquelle un avion serait actuellement
sur la piste de l'aéroport du bourget
près de paris et éventuellement pour
emmener vers l'iran veuille doors jimi
là il ne faut pas aller trop vite en
besogne
bien entendu mais nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler dans ce journal que la
démocratie est un bien précieux
inestimable et difficile à conquérir le
peuple haïtien en fait la tragique
expérience aujourd'hui haïti l'un des
pays les plus pauvres du monde devait
avoir lieu ce dimanche après trente
années de dictature
le premier vote libre les tristement
célèbres tontons macoutes hommes de main
au service de l'ex dictateur duvalier en
ont voulu autrement ils sont parvenus à
leurs fins en semant la terreur dans le
pays
commettant plusieurs dizaines
d'attentats d'assassinats aveugle
obligeant le gouvernement provisoire
annulé finalement le scrutin qui avait
débuté ce matin de bonne heure au
téléphone
le témoignage de notre envoyé spécial
martin laroche joubert bloqué avec des
dizaines d'autres journalistes étrangers
quelque part dans la ville de port au
prince la capitale
martin
mais à peu près correctement à port au
prince parce qu'on entend des été
entendu pendant la nuit on a entendu des
tirs et des tours aux modes qui ont été
à sens et ce même s'il ya des stations
tour à dimension esthétique raillé le à
la grenade
bon comme sommes défendus il ya des
bureaux de vote vers surtout regarder
les filles de gens absolument déterminés
à voter tous suivant paul votron cet
incident c'est ce que nous avons
constaté dès le départ c'est que harper
n'était pas dans les mousses et une
présence d une manne que les deux jours
devant les bureaux code c'était
absolument pas procéder si ce soir c'est
pour s'enfermer maintenant qu'on peut
sortir les journalistes sont bloqués
dans un hôtel moi même bloqué dans un
autre endroit
donc je sais pas grand chose et mathieu
ford et ceci posé quatre personnes dans
les rues tous les jours maintenant
vraiment heures et que la situation
un temps tiré je pense que les ont
extraits vous voulez c'est quelque chose
de capital
c'est le premier pas vers la démocratie
il fallait absolument voter c'est très
important pour eux d'élire leur
président donc je dois y avoir aidé en
partie de population
allez dans la démocratie est adhérente
et par bateau probablement par une
fraction de l'armée alors comme vient de
le dire martine laroche-joubert les
tontons macoutes armés jusqu'aux dents
de mitraillettes et de machettes ont
semé la terreur tout au long de ce
dimanche assassinant et blessant au
hasard des dizaines de personnes qui se
présentaient devant les yeux des
journalistes ont également été victimes
de ces mercenaires
un confrère de nationalité dominicaine
est mort alors qu'il se trouvait dans un
bureau de vote de port-au-prince
à cet endroit se trouvait également un
journaliste français qui témoignait
aussi au téléphone et à l'intérieur de
claude lévesque il était arrivé montant
des pensions très grande
brusquement 50 armées de haches sont
arrivés et ont attaqué le dos il
comptait les prés de roncq à l'intérieur
du bureau et on va s'axer en coin 15 et
20 personnes a lâché environ
avec des as et les lords allons pouvoir
les habitations et un petit pan série
comme spectacle et après nous sommes
revenus quoique que la taille et on a
découvert un spectacle et à comment les
mac ou encore une deuxième fois en
tirant des bombes alliées l'angle était
cinq ou six
hélas lors la tête et de nouveau une
attaque en règle et il y avait plus
grand monde d'enduro de corte en fait
lyrique journal relatant la vie combat
c'est terrible on revient de loin
oui sur ce témoignage vous avez pu voir
les premières images qui nous
parvenaient à l'instant même de
port-au-prince via les états unis sont
les premières images que nous recevons
aujourd'hui d'haïti en france la police
accélère ses opérations antiterroristes
et cela encore suis personne inculpée
d'attentats ont été transférés à paris
avant-hier elle ferait partie de la
hiérarchie de l'ex flnc deux autres ont
été arrêtés hier soir samedi soir elles
appartiennent au syndicat des
travailleurs corses l'un d'eux bernard
trojani et le secrétaire général de
l'organisation il a été interpellé dans
le cadre de l' enquête sur l'assassinât
d'un gendarme
c'était le 4 août dernier près de bastia
gera beaufils les mailles du filet
policier se resserre en effet au tour du
syndicat des travailleurs corses la plus
jeune des organisations syndicales de
l'île qui compte selon ses dires près de
mille adhérents
selon la brigade de recherches de la
gendarmerie de corse du sud
cinq des militants arrêtés ajaccio
serait donc proche de l'ex fnlc
l'organisation terroriste aujourd'hui
dissoute
si la violence politique existe dans ce
pays
il ya des problèmes politiques qui lie à
la pointe des développements qui a des
problèmes de reconnaissance des droits
du peuple corse et que malheureusement
tant que ces problèmes ne seront pas
réglés globalement dans le cadre d'une
pause d'une solution politique
malheureusement je le pense avenance
poétique existera toujours le 4 août
dernier un véhicule de gendarmerie tombe
dans une véritable embuscade sur la
route qui mène à l'aéroport de bastia
le gendarme guy asnar est tué sur le
coup et deux de ses collègues
grièvement blessé le juge michel legrand
souhaite entendre demain les personnes
interpellées dans le cadre de cette
sanglante à faire il ne s'agit pour
l'instant que de vérifier les emplois du
temps des cinq militants du syndicat des
travailleurs corses afin de déterminer
s'ils ont pu ou non participé à cette
fusillade tragique à bord d'un véhicule
volé puis retrouvé le jour même
les tueurs en fête aurait été aperçue et
même reconnu au moment de leur fuite
l' enquête devrait connaître des
développements importants au cours de
ces prochains jours le mouvement sos
racisme appelait à une manifestation
aujourd'hui à paris contre la xénophobie
et le racisme et pour l'égalité des
droits
dominique verdalle nous sommes tous des
enfants d'immigrés main dans la main
c'est humain couscous cassoulet même
combat c'est quelques-uns des slogans
que l'on pouvait entendre cet après midi
entre montparnasse et bastille plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
avaient répondu présent à l'appel de
l'eswc est racisme de l'unef et de 40
autres organisations pour une
manifestation contre le racisme et la
xénophobie
ils participaient des hommes politiques
mais aussi des journalistes op sportif
des écrivains et des personnalités du
monde du spectacle ordinaire
il ya de la musique toutes les peaux
toutes les cultures tout le même
j'espère même en dehors des partis en
dehors de l'idée
jeudi on est réuni pour une même
idéologie intégration tolérance telle
était la devise de ceux qui scandaient
black blanc beur égalité des droits
un rassemblement que les jeunes
souhaitent est situé sur un terrain
pacifiste je pense que c'est la
solidarité tout le monde le dit de tous
les côtés qui manque en france
peu de gens le vivent il fallait que
cette journée existe pour cela
j'ignore s'il a rempli sa mission j'ai
entendu des phrases qui m'ont fait chaud
au coeur
par exemple fraternité égalité quand je
le racisme pas de race et tout ça ça
sera fait plaisir donc j'espère que ce
moment-là continuera et que c'est dit
sincèrement les manifestants se sont
dispersés au pied de la colonne de la
bastille symbole de liberté égalité
fraternité
le défilé s'est achevé comme il avait
commencé au son de samba de musique
berbère et de rock
oui réunis à lyon les mouvements
indépendantistes et nationalistes corses
calédonien guadeloupéens ont adopté une
motion dans laquelle ils condamnent ce
qu'ils appellent la politique répressive
de l'état français c'était ce week end à
lyon second tour très attendu de
l'élection cantonale de marseille la
bataille entre le candidat de la
majorité et de l'opposition étaient
arbitrés par le front national qui
comptabilisait 18 % des voix au premier
tour et qui avait donné comme consigne
l'abstention pour aujourd'hui et bien
malgré cela pourrait-on dire c'est le
candidat de la majorité robert assante
qui a été et tout de suite à marseille
nous rejoignons daniel bref daniel oui
et bien officiellement nous avons vingt
bureaux sur 21 et monsieur as en tête en
tête avec 350 bois il y a eu 9 36 % de
votants en plus c'est donc là qu'il faut
trouver la différence
il y a eu aussi les communistes en moins
voté au fonds national beaucoup de
bulletins nuls et il ya une plus forte
mobilisation du rpr il me manque donc un
bureau mais certainement les résultats
ne varieront pas et il y à vous le voyez
la participation à midi était propre
sentent plus à 16h et l'effet de 5% en
plus et ensuite à la clôture de 9 36% de
plus voilà monsieur manivet en train de
voter bien alors d'asnières est ce que
nous avons déjà des réactions monsieur
gaudin ou mais je crois que vous avez dû
enregistrer monsieur gaudin où il y est
il y a eu à la permanence une explosion
de joie parce que les partis ont les
chiffres plus vite et ils font leurs
totaux encore plus vite bien alors nous
allons voir à tout de suite daniel est
ce que nous avons je vais interroger la
régie est ce que nous avons un diamant
où le doyen qui regarde mes chers amis
viens de vous dire que grâce à l'union
totale du rassemblement pour la
république et de lui dire que grâce aux
qualités de notre quartier
que grâce à votre combativité et à
l'effort que vous avez pu faire pendant
cette campagne électorale la majorité la
majorité remporte ce canton et c'est un
événement très important aujourd'hui
compte tenu de la semaine que nous
venons de vie ce qui veut dire ce qui
veut dire que la droite libérale dont on
a tenté de la mettre en difficulté
so victorieuse pourquoi parce qu'à
marseille on n'aime pas bien les
injonctions venues d'ailleurs
voilà la réaction tout marseillaise et
plein de bonheur on le comprend de
monsieur jean claude gaudin après
l'élection de son candidat puisque c'est
le candidat udf qui l'a emporté ce soir
à marseille
la suite de l'actualité politique les
phrases du week-end c'est d'abord
monsieur raymond barre qui à toulouse
avait réuni tous les élus de france qui
font campagne pour lui
bernard pradines
je crois profondément au rôle de la
grande équipe de france que vous formez
de cette équipe de la france
décentralisée capable d'apporter au
pouvoir central
un regard original et début constructif
sur les problèmes du pays et sur la
construction de son avenir
si il n'y avait pas de majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et si par exemple
on est dissolvait pas si le futur
président se dissolvait pas eh bien il y
aurait encore un gouvernement de
cohabitation
or moi je pense que ce n'est pas
réaliste parce que le président
nouvellement élu sera forcément
rapidement identifié au gouvernement
qu'il aura désigné si il y à un candidat
socialiste qui est élu président la
république ce qu'à dieu ne plaise mois
de mai 88
c'est à lui qu'il appartiendra de se
trouver devant une situation simple où
l'ue respecte l'assemblée nationale
telle qu'elle est où il ya une majorité
eu des frp air et par conséquent le
gouvernement du moment sera un
gouvernement
edf kpn ont bien et il décide de
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
et alors on verse au deuxième tour
j'appellerai à battre la droite et
l'extrême droite
j'appellerai à ne pas s'abstenir à ne
pas déserter le combat mais je le ferai
sans donner de chèque en blanc sans
donner de bilan sain ni à un homme ni à
un parti pour les phrases politiques du
week end sur scène non perturbations
attendues demain sur air inter tous les
syndicats appellent à une grève pour
répondre à la décision du tribunal de
bobigny qui avait considéré comme
illicite
le préavis de grève déposé la semaine
dernière par les syndicats d'air inter
demain également journée de défense des
libertés syndicales organisées par la
cgt dans les entreprises en relation
avec la greffe des reins terre mais
aussi la mort du militant communiste
lucien barbier et le licenciement des
syndicalistes de chèques cgt de chez
renault
en pologne le général jarre uzès qui
organisait aujourd'hui un référendum
portant sur des réformes politiques et
économiques surtout pour tenter de
sortir le pays du marasme actuel
malgré le découragement des polonais qui
ne croient plus guère aux changements la
participation au vote a été soutenue
c'est tout ce que l'on peut dire pour
l'instant
des manifestations organisées par l'ex
syndicat solidarité ont également eu
lieu dans le fief de solidarité ac dans
le grand port de la baltique
jacques berlinoise pour mettre toutes
les chances de son côté le gouvernement
polonais a fixé à 22 heures la fermeture
des bureaux de vote
car l'enjeu de ce référendum n'est pas
le nombre de wii il sera sans doute
supérieur à 80% mais le taux de
participation
encore faudrait-il d'ailleurs que les
chiffres ne soient pas truqué c'est bien
évidemment sur ce point on ne possède
aucune garantie
l'évaluation la plus probable avant la
clôture est une participation d'environ
60%
ce qui n'est si le chiffre est vrai ni
un succès ni un échec mais ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre que ce train de réformes
portant sur une réorganisation de
l'économie une ouverture démocratique va
se traduire d'abord en janvier prochain
par une terrible hausses de prix plus
110 % pour les produits alimentaires et
de 100 à 200 % pour le fuel ou
l'électricité
ce sont des chiffres terribles pour
cette pologne il n'arrive pas à sortir
d'une crise économique dramatique
la question posée donc tout à fait
simple comment le peuple polonais hancké
sera-t-il ces hausses qui entreront en
vigueur dès le mois prochain si l'on en
croit l influence de conserves
solidarnosc et que l'on peut observer
ici à quelques mètres de la tombe du
père popieluszko il est tout à fait
possible d'envisager que la pologne dès
le mois prochain connaissent un profond
mouvement de révolte ont tenté de
reprendre la situation en main le
nouveau numéro un afghan soutenu par les
soviétiques réunissait aujourd'hui à
kaboul la capitale les 1500 chefs
coutumiers venus de tous les coins du
pays
une cérémonie contesté à coups de
roquettes par les maquisards afghan
hostiles au régime actuel jean pierre
métivier le nouvel homme fort de
l'afghanistan le docteur najibullah son
discours a débuté voici à peine dix
minutes ce matin quand quatre roquettes
explose tout près du bâtiment
cela nous ne le verrons pas sur ces
images de la télévision soviétique
il s'agit de la riposte des résistants
afghans à la convocation par kaboul
d'une loya jirga
l'une de ses grandes assemblées
traditionnelles la septième seulement
depuis le début du siècle les chefs
coutumiers sont descendus des montagnes
et moi ceux qui n'ont pas rallié la
résistance au total 15 cents délégués
aujourd'hui adopter une nouvelle
constitution
demain ils choisiront le nouveau
président qui a toutes les chances
d'être monsieur najibullah l'ex-chef des
services secrets afghans président en
titre depuis septembre dernier
la résistance a qualifié cette réunion
de faste farce
c'est la deuxième du genre depuis qu'un
contingent soviétique 115 mille hommes
aujourd'hui stationnent en afghanistan
sujet médical pour terminer la sema
l'asthme est une maladie souvent
chronique une gêne respiratoire qui
touche près de 2 millions de français
l'asthme n'est pas en régression au
contraire dans les grandes villes même
il y en a de plus en plus et les enfants
de plus en plus jeunes sont atteints
c'est ce qui a poussé les spécialistes
de cette maladie respiratoire a lancé
une campagne de sensibilisation sur donc
cette maladie là encore mal connues
finalement alain rabou classe ne sais
quoi pour toi bats je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui a un problème pulmonaire
pour moi je pense que c'est une maladie
des voies respiratoires
le thillot passe l'air il se il se
resserre et
une pasta avec quinze années d'asthme
derrière l ain sait de quoi elle parle
pour elle tout a commencé à l'âge de
trois mois par des bronchites un peu
spéciale dès branchies qui sifflaient et
qui provoquait des gênes respiratoires
de plus en plus importante
allergique aux poils d'animaux anne a dû
être hospitalisé à plusieurs reprises
pour des crises d'asthme qui l'asphyxié
aujourd'hui un essaye de retrouver une
vie normale et un peu comme vivre je
suis pas moi c'est pareil c'est pas
vraiment un handicap c'est au fond vivre
avec six fois au début c'est sûr mais je
me disais je pensais que j'allais m'en
débarrasser mais finalement apprendre
m'a fait comprendre que que j'aurais
quand même toute ma vie mais je ferai
pas des crises d'asthme tout le temps
comment tu vois l'avenir maintenant marc
et j'espère que ça va s'améliorer de
plus en plus c'est que je serai de moins
en moins de jeunes enfants seraient de
plus en plus comme les autres
aujourd'hui au moins un enfant sur vingt
est asthmatique et ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à être touchés par cette
maladie respiratoire une maladie liée
indiscutablement à la pollution ambiante
une maladie qui survient aussi chez des
enfants de plus en plus jeunes à partir
de quel âge on peut observer des achats
chez l'enfant très tôt dans la vie avant
l'âge de 3 ans chez le nourrisson
contrairement à ce qu'on disait
auparavant la deuxième notion importante
c'est que tous les asthmes de l'enfant
ne sont pas de nature allergiques quand
on a fait un diagnostic d'asthme chez
l'enfant il faut le traiter très tôt et
de manière extrêmement vigilante et
rigoureuse dans le temps et c'est de
mettre en place des mesures de
prévention par exemple chez un enfant à
risque dont les deux parents sont
asthmatiques allergiques
il faudra mettre en place chez lui une
chambre vide sans poussière c'est à dire
100 laine sans plumes sans jouets des
peluches en évitant l'apport à domicile
des animaux familiers à poils ou à
plumes
la prévention est donc possible grâce à
elle et grâce aussi à la mise au point
de nouveaux traitements
l'assm ne devrait plus être aujourd'hui
une maladie qui tue il est 20 heures 24
maintenant nous sommes arrivés parce
qu'au terme de ce journal avant de nous
quitter je voudrais que nous retournions
un instant au palais de justice où vahid
gordji donc qui est sorti de l'ambassade
d'iran où il se trouvait depuis plus de
cinq mois maintenant
s'est interrogé par le juge boulouque
hervé tout à fait bien gagner nous
sommes maintenant à plus de deux heures
d'audition
vous savez juge boulouque est un
magistrat qui a toujours dit qu'il
ferait son travail dans cette affaire
que lorsque gordji serait dans son
bureau il vérifierait les emplois du
temps les mises en cause de gorji par
les uns et les autres je vous propose de
voir ces quelques images que nous venons
tout juste de tourner il ya quelques
minutes plusieurs voitures sont arrivées
ici à bord de l'une d'elles un homme
était couché peut-être s'agit-il d'un
témoin peut être le juge boulouque at il
voulu provoquer une confrontation dans
son bureau
mais attention daniel je vous livre ses
informations au conditionnel
voilà daniel merci à hervé pour ce
dernier point il était important il y à
une dépêche très importante qui vient de
tomber à l'instant je vous la litière et
on va peut-être la commenter ensemble
le consul de france à téhéran cette
dépêche est datée de nicosie et c'est
une dépêche à ces pelles
consul de france à téhéran monsieur paul
tories accusés d'espionnage et de divers
trafics par la justice iranienne a
comparu dimanche à téhéran devant un
tribunal révolutionnaire islamique
c'est ce qu'a annoncé donc radio téhéran
capté à nicosie pierre va écouter c'est
une mesure de réciprocité je crois que
c'est la preuve que la négociation est
en cours et que justement chacun de son
côté
sauve la face on a à gorges icher juge
boulouque en à monsieur trichet juge
iranien je pense qu'ils vont sortir tous
les deux bien en tout cas je crois que
nous avons fait là le point le plus
complet possible sur cette affaire ce
soir bien sûr dans la soirée si cela
s'impose
nour et interviendront bien avant le
dernier journal présenté tout à l'heure
en fin de programme par philippe
millasseau nous interviendrons par
exemple aux alentours de 21h35 c'est à
dire tout de suite après la première
émission de la soirée la soirée
consacrée à cadets roucas donc 21h35 ce
sera sans aucun doute votre prochain
rendez vous avec la rédaction d'antenne
2 avec moi même pour les derniers
événements
à propos de cette audition devait
gorgier de tous ces évènements qui
s'enchaînent ce soit autour de cette
audition par le juge d'instruction au
palais de justice de paris
nous allons terminer ce journal par
d'abord les résultats du tiercé qui ne
faut pas oublier il y a des joueurs de
tir c'est qu'ils attendent
les voici ces rapports du tiercé
aujourd'hui neuf as 8
et puis il ya également les rapports du
quartier qui s'inscrivent juste en
dessous sur cette même image vous laisse
le temps de les déchiffrer de les lire
et puis de noter la somme si vous avez
empoché et si vous l'avez empoché et si
vous avez gagné
on va tout de suite maintenant prendre
des nouvelles de la météo pour terminer
sophie bien daniel je me propose une
orgie vrai pour demain avec des
brouillards et des gelées blanches qui
seront fréquences sur le centre du pays
attention si vous prenez la route demain
matin des plaques de zinc sommes fondés
par des plaques de verglas et l'ouest du
pays
mais dans l'ensemble ce sera une belle
journée d'automne avec un soleil
dominateur son languedoc-roussillon sur
le centre sur l'île de france et sur le
nord des nuages un petit peu plus
abondant à l'ouest et puis les nuages
qui s'accrochent au relief des alpes
avec encore des chutes de neige quelques
petits flocons également sur le nord-est
et puis des averses sur la corse
côté températures c'est toujours très
frais
2° seulement amis ou jusqu'à 9 à brest
pour la moitié sud 4 degrés à lyon
jusqu'à 13 en corse et puis demain nous
serons le lundi 30 novembre
les derniers jours du mois et nous
fêterons les andré voilà denek merci
sophy avant de quitter je voudrais vous
dire que le journaliste que nous avons
entendu tout à leur témoigner à propos
des événements en haïti et que et qui
était pour l'instant anonyme est en
réalité didier chauffier c'est un de nos
confrères de tf1 donc qui nous a apporté
tout à l'heure très chaleureusement et
très gentiment son témoignage sur les
événements en haïti
alors donc le prochain rendez vous avec
la formation ce sera sans aucun doute
aux alentours de 21h35 poursuivre
ensemble le dernier événement à propos
de la sphère gordji et puis ensuite en
fin de programme vous retrouverez pour
un point complet cette fois-ci philippe
gassot voilà j'espère que nous nous
retrouverons tout à l'heure avec
d'autres informations en attendant je
vous laisse passer une excellente soirée
sur antenne 2 bien sûr bonsoir à tout à
l'heure
e